called Clara guide dog school which
trains and provides kya dogs free after
the situation in Greek and streets is
very very bad I was bumping in obstacles
all the time I remained my life brighter
the things in my life was so radically
that I decided that I had to do
something so that other people receive
this gift
it's a very serious thing you cannot
take a dog in the black person and just
take them out on the street like that
especially the big one if the guy doc
tones why is it turning because he found
an obstacle or because it needs to go to
the bathroom you know to have to be in
constant communication in my case I was
in the bus and the bus driver of the
police because I was the older dog my
dream is that a larger guide of school
that would really be China's all is
obtainable and autonomous and that the
week society will eventually learn to
respond to our needs blind people can do
anything they will he fair properly
trained and lick it with respect
you